after creating and running Saturday
Night Live for five seasons Lauren
Michaels stepped away from the sketch
comedy to work on some other TV projects
as a result the show's sixth season
which ran from 1980 to 1981 turned out
to be an incredibly tumultuous year for
the creatives on SNL although much of
the chaos ensued behind the scenes there
were some on-screen shifts that rendered
the shows comedy pretty forgettable so
forgettable in fact that people rarely
bring up any moments from this season at
all unless they're talking about how
disastrously bad it was here's what you
might not know about Saturday Night
Live's forgotten season Breaking Away
after five years of putting in the
intense time and effort it takes to make
SNL shine Lauren Michaels decided he
needed to take a step back from the
executive chair for a bit at first he
just wanted the summer off and to delay
the sixth season premiere - just after
the 1980 election instead of the usual
September's start but Michaels also
admitted he wasn't sure if he wanted to
come back at all because to continue the
show men he'd have to sacrifice other
ambitions so he floated some ideas to
NBC about who should take over in his
absence just in case his top choice was
for SNL writers and occasional
performers Al Franken and Tom Davis to
take over he figured they'd be the best
candidates to maintain the quality
integrity and tone of the show since
they'd all worked together for so long
but he doomed frankenz chances before
the possibility could even materialize
Michaels had been scheduled to meet with
NBC President Fred Silverman to discuss
their future but Silverman had to
postpone then the weekend before the
rescheduled appointment Franken appeared
on a segment of Weekend Update that
specifically targeted the head honcho
you know who gets complete door to door
limousine service from NBC Fred
Silverman Franken said in the piece and
it wasn't fair that he should have to
hail cabs in New York while Silverman
got to take a limousine wherever he
wanted even while NBC was failing in the
ratings I like to call it a limo for the
lame-o Silverman saw the episode and
lost his cool with Michaels the
relationship between Michaels and the
network's soured so badly that Michaels
decided to walk away from SNL completely
and Silverman overlooked Franken as
Michaels replacement regrouping a few
weeks after his spat with NBC brass
Michaels got a call from another exec
who had informed him that his successor
would be Gene dumain Ian
an associate producer for the show
Michael Sidhu Manian was quote an
interesting choice because he felt SNL
was quote a writer based show and
Dumaine ian had been on the writing
staff for exactly one TV variety special
but her years on SNL did give her the
knowledge of how the show was assembled
each week and domain Ian's skills as a
talent coordinator would come in handy
that's because when Michaels left so did
the entire cast of Saturday Night Live
including Jane Curtin Bill Murray
Garrett Morris
Larry Newman and Gilda Radner so that
meant de Manian had to assemble an
entirely new cast she put together a
roster that included Deni Dillon Gilbert
Godfried Joe Piscopo
and Eddie Murphy although Murphy was not
the first choice for the new roster he
continuously contacted talent
coordinator Neil levy until he gave the
comedian a chance to audition little did
anyone know that Murphy's audition
routine would come in handy later on in
the show see almost every writer left
with Lorne Michaels in the cast so
domain Ian's had to recruit a new stable
of talent behind the scenes too but with
the writers room becoming its own sort
of revolving door while she was in
charge there was a shortage of sketches
in one case they were running five
minutes short on material and decided at
the last minute to f Murphy go out and
perform his stand-up routine to fill
empty airtime the 19 year old became the
actual saving grace of the entire season
after that multiple missteps despite the
introduction of Murphy as a rising star
the sixth season of SNL was still filled
with snafus for example in the cold open
of the season premiere host Elliott
Gould wakes up in bed with some new cast
members and they're immediately compared
to the show's former cast members sort
of a cross between Gilda and Jane in
other words the show's new era began
with an unfavorable comparison to its
old iteration and it was a steep slide
down from there in one episode some good
old boys try to shoot communists and one
character used the n-word but the season
wasn't just offensive it was all so
boring in bizarre there was a 5 minute
long sketch about a couple who can't
remember the name of their friend's cat
the leather weather report featuring
Denny Dillon as a dominatrix named
Thelma Thunder giving her S&M theme
forecast
perhaps most idiotically Weekend Update
was ditched in favor of a failed segment
called Saturday night news line in what
became the most infamous incident of the
season on episode 11
in February cast member Charles rocket
dropped an f-bomb on live air the show
lost 30% of its audience and critics
maligned the new direction
the New York Times even called it an
unfunny parody of its predecessor that
relied too heavily on racial and sexual
humor
if the execs wanted to salvage their hit
series they'd have to think fast
beginning again after the twelfth
episode of the season one after Charles
Rockets f-word incident dumain ian was
relieved from her position as SNL
producer her replacement was NBC
executive Dick Ebersol who'd actually
help develop Saturday Night Live in the
mid-70s immediately after taking over
Eversole fired most of the cast
including Charles rocket Gilbert Godfrey
and Risley Yvonne Hudson Matthew
Lawrence and Patrick weathers in their
places he brought in SCTV stars Robin
Duke and Tony Rosato as well as Tim
kazarinski
Laurie Metcalf and National Lampoon
editor Emily Prager were also hired as
featured players by the time the season
was finished ever saw also fired gael
mathias and Denny Dillon so the only
domain Ian hires to survive the season
where breakout stars Eddie Murphy and
Joe Piscopo thanks to Murphy status as
the MVP of the season he became the
first featured player promoted to
regular cast member during his first
season on the show bad timing
what set all these massive changes into
motion was producer Lorne Michaels
wanting a break in the fall of 1980
ironically had he just stayed at the
show and said nothing to NBC he probably
would have gotten one the sixth season
of SNL didn't actually air its first
episode until November 15 1980 about two
months late all because of a Screen
Actors Guild strike but luckily for
everyone involved with the disaster
plague season it also ended early cut
short abruptly after the 13th episode
due to a writer's strike the 14th
episode had already been planned and it
might have helped get SNL back on track
as a guest on Weekend Update would be
showrunner Al Franken announced he'd be
back the next week to host and offered a
scathing monologue about how he was
hell-bent on repairing the broken season
anyway
NBC 12 shows to figure out their
horrendous mistake but the
strike-shortened season led to some of
the shortest 10 years in SNL history
featured players Laurie Metcalf and
Emily Prager were let go after the de
facto season finale and Metcalf only
appeared in one pre-taped bit for
Weekend Update
while Prager never officially appeared
on this show at all thanks to the
brevity of the season and so many cast
and creative shakeups it's hardly any
wonder why SNL 6th season hasn't shown
up much in the highlight reel but hey at
least it introduced the world to Eddie
Murphy thanks for watching click the
looper icon to subscribe to our YouTube
channel plus check out all the school
stuff we know you'll love to
[Music]
[Applause]